imagine this scenario you're running an
analytics workload in google cloud that
reads data from google cloud storage and
processes it using a data flow job the
amount of data that the job processes
has been growing but your pipeline
hasn't had any issues keeping up
you're having lunch when you get an
alert on your phone your pipeline is
returning processing errors
you'll abandon your lunch open your
laptop and start investigating
sure enough the dataflow job is failing
and it turns out that cloud storage
requests are resulting in 429 too many
request errors
this has never happened before what
could be going on
well it's possible you've exhausted a
quota in your project and the job is
being throttled
my name is yuri and i'm a site
reliability engineer at google today i'm
going to show you how to proactively
monitor quotas and get notified when you
start to approach the limit so that you
can raise the quota and avoid problems
like this one welcome to engineering for
reliability with google cloud
okay let's dig into this and figure out
if the errors you're seeing are actually
due to running out a quota
we can start on the quotas page here we
can see that we've run out of egress
bandwidth quota in this region
let's go to the products menu and select
metrics explorer under monitoring here
we can plot quota usage against quota
limit over time
both of these metrics are available for
the consumer quota resource
the usage metric is called rate quota
usage rate quotas are typically used for
limiting the number of requests you can
make to an api or service and are
applied over a specific time interval in
this case the quota is egress bandwidth
per second the other kind of quota is an
allocation quota which restricts how
many resources you can have provisioned
at a time such as the number of vms in
the project
they reset when the resources are
released when the vms are deleted for
example
the other metric we need here is the
quota limit metric which tells us what
the limit for this rate usage is
there's another way to view this data
we can use mql the monitoring query
language to actually calculate a ratio
of quarter usage to quota limit we'll
post a link for this query in the
episode notes here we clearly see that
our usage to limit ratio exceeded one
for a period of time this explains why
our job was throttled
so now we know that we did exhaust
network eager exploder and that's why
our job got throttled and started
failing we submitted a quota increase
request which unblocked our job our
pipeline is back up and running
we don't want this to keep happening
right
let's set up an alert that will notify
us if we get close to the new increased
quota
let's start on the alerting screen and
create a new alerting policy we'll use
mql to define this policy
paste the query here and run it to
evaluate both the query we've written to
calculate the usage limit ratio and the
threshold for that ratio that we want to
use to trigger the alert
that threshold is defined here in the
last statement in the query using a
condition statement
looks like our signal is correct
we need to name our condition
[Music]
and specify how we want to be notified
the next time the alert fires
we also want to specify whether the
incident should be automatically closed
after some amount of time passes
let's name the
alert and review the policy to validate
that we've defined our signal and
threshold correctly
and i think we did
and that's how you can use mql to
calculate the usage to limit ratio and
set up alerting to be notified when you
start approaching a quota limit in your
project
great now if we start to get close to
the quota we'll get an alert so we can
avoid having our job be throttled again
that's engineering for reliability
thanks so much for watching today don't
forget to like and subscribe to never
miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon
[Music]
you